The Origin of the QWERTY Keyboard
The first typewriter was introduced to the
United States in 1868 by Christopher Latham
Sholes.
His first attempt to build a typing device
consisted of a crude and sluggish machine
that was far from perfect.
The design used letters and characters on
the ends of rods which were called typebars.
When a key was struck, the typebar would swing
up and hit the ink-coated tape which would
transfer the image onto paper.
The original design of the keyboard positioned
keys in alphabetical order in two rows.
Makes sense, right?
Well, this arrangement caused the typebars
of the most commonly used combination letters
of the alphabet (ie.
TH and ST) to be positioned close together,
so when the keys were hit right after the
other with a speed faster than a snail, the
keys would jam.
The attempt to solve this malfunction resulted
in a rearrangement of keys.
In 1868, in collaboration with educator Amos
Densmore, Sholes arranged the letters on the
keyboard for better spacing between popular
keys used in combination.
The results was that this initially made it
difficult for people to find the letters they
needed to type efficiently.
However, someone who mastered this new key
arrangement would actually be able to type
faster because the keys wouldn’t jam.
This was the beginning of the QWERTY keyboard,
which first appeared in 1872.
The first typewriter machine found its way
on the market in 1874 through Remington & Sons.
The device was called the Remington No. 1.
You’re probably thinking it sold out in
minutes since it was the latest and greatest
technological device to be mass-produced.
The truth is, most people ignored it.
Sure, the machine still had some quirks and
Sholes had yet to figure out ideal customers
for his invention, but in the late 1870s,
the idea of “mechanical writing” was just
plain strange for most people.
The accepted norm was to write letters in
legible longhand and many people found mechanical
writing uncouth or even offensive.
Sholes figured his device would appeal to
clergyman and men of letters first and then
he’d branch out to the general public; he
didn’t even consider its use in business.
All of these factors probably played a part
in the typewriter’s initial lack of sales.
Four years later, after slight modifications
to the arrangement of the keyboard were made,
Remington & Sons produced the new Remington
No. 2 model.
The Remington No. 2 included the arrangement
of keys we use today along with the ability
to type both capital and lowercase letters
by using the shift key.
The shift key received its name because it
caused the carriage to shift position in order
to type either a lowercase or capital letter
which were on the same typebar.
Although the shift key we use on our keyboards
today does not cause the machine to shift
mechanically, the name stuck.
As the typewriter rose in popularity, people
stopped complaining about the weird arrangement
of keys and started memorizing the keyboard
and learning how to type efficiently.
Although other alternate keyboards tried to
break onto the market, most people decided
to stay with the QWERTY board, and none of
the other type-writing machines proved successful.
One prominent attempt at a replacement keyboard
occurred in the early 1930s when Professor
August Dvorak of Washington State University
set out to develop a more user-friendly keyboard.
He ultimately redesigned the keyboard so all
of the vowels and the five most commonly used
consonants were arranged on the home row (AOEUIDHTNS).
Although the design required a typist to frequently
alternate hands to type most words, with the
Dvorak keyboard, a person could type approximately
400 of the English language’s most common
words just by using the keys of the home row,
compared to 100 words on the QWERTY keyboard.
In addition, using the Dvorak keyboard, a
typist’s fingers would not have to travel
as far as they did on Sholes’ keyboard to
type the majority of words.
Dvorak set out to prove his machine superior
to Sholes’, but his keyboard never caught
on.
Many of the studies used to test the effectiveness
of his keyboard were flawed or were deemed
a conflict of interest since Dvorak conducted
them himself.
A U.S. General Services Administration study
in 1953 of Dvorak’s keyboard determined
it didn’t matter which keyboard was used.
Experienced typists in either keyboard typed
at approximately the same speed, with variance
based more on their individual skill rather
than either keyboard design being superior
to the other in a larger samplesize or words.
This ultimately killed the Dvorak keyboard
as the majority of people didn’t want to
commit the time or resources it would take
to be trained on a new keyboard.
Thus, the QWERTY keyboard persevered through
today and seemingly will continue to do so
for the foreseeable future.
As Dr. Dvorak said, “Changing the keyboard
format is like proposing to reverse the Ten
Commandments and the Golden Rule, discard
every moral principle, and ridicule motherhood.”
Bonus Facts:
• Author Mark Twain was one of the first
people to purchase the early typewriter and
is probably the first author to submit a typed
manuscript to his publisher.
• Frank McGurrin, a court stenographer from
Salt Lake City, is considered the first person
to master touch-typing on the QWERTY keyboard,
as opposed to the hunt-and-peck method most
at the time used.
He rose to fame when he participated in typing
contests and demonstrations across the country
and caused people to take interest not only
in the QWERTY keyboard, but in mastering the
touch-typing method.